guys remember back in May 2015 we made
like 8 videos about it
remember back in August when faze clan
sued t foo well since a summer [ __ ] show
of lawsuits drama reports and tell-all
videos things have kind of calmed down a
bit that is until now
nearly four months after faze clan first
filed their lawsuit against t foo t Fu's
legal team has officially fired back
[Music]
guys I have in my hand T Fu's official
legal response to the new york-based
lawsuit against him it is called
defendant Turner tiny p'kat Fu's answer
to plaintiffs complaint not exactly a
page turner title and it was filed in
the southern district court of New York
on November 21st now those of you who
have been following this case already
know that Teague filed his old legal
complaint against faze clan in
California first and all Teague and his
legal team have done up to this point to
respond to the New York lawsuit is to
try to get it thrown out or at least
delayed until the California one has
finished well of judge in this case said
no and it looks like all that's out the
window and this new york case is going
to proceed now time for a super quick
recap for anyone who needs a refresher
in t food lawsuits at 101 2018 people's
lawyer sent letters to faze clan trying
to get him out of his contract alleging
faceplant breached that contract and
owes and money in may 2000 1982 Spacelab
he alleges that his contract under face
was grossly oppressive and illegal in so
far as faze clan was acting at a talent
agency in the state of california when
out having a license to do so he was
contractor meets shortly after we hear
the scoring sports get an exclusive
interview with keepers lawyer who breaks
the fact that people tried to modify or
change his contract before moving to
actually soon phase clamp man we
interview faze clan CEO who drops him
their entire signed a story and their
legal defense to that lawsuit in August
fazed hairdressers TSP this time in the
state of New York
alleges he stole trade secrets he
breached his contract and made 20
million dollars under face and that he
also apparently wanted to start a rival
or finally people's lawyers trying to
get the New York tasty to thrown out or
delayed they are unsuccessful now that
all that is out of the way and we're all
caught up
what does t Fu's response to faze clans
lawsuit actually say the first part of
it is a point-by-point paragraph by
paragraph response to every single thing
phase is suing him for and a lot of them
pretty much boiled down to the legal
equivalent of know you for example
t Fu's response denies his lawsuit and
his conduct damaged phase clans business
and brand in any way it denies the
original gamer agreement contract was
legal and enforceable it did
nice heõs phase money it denies he
slandered and disparaged faze clan to
cause financial harm it denies he tried
to entice other phase streamers like
cloak seat to leave the org it denies he
stole faze clan trade secrets and it
denies he's using those secrets to start
his own competing eSports org
now the second half of T Fu's legal
response is by far the more interesting
part it lists 25 individual defenses
some of which we've heard before and
some of which are new and I want to
start with the most mysterious of the
bunch there are a number of these
different defenses that hinge on what
this document only refers to as the
alleged statements but it's pretty clear
they're pertaining to public comments
that T foo made about phase at least
that's my understanding and in phase
clans lawsuit they alleged that teeth
who made slanderous comments about faze
clan that he lied about the org and
disclosed parts of his contract that he
shouldn't have phases lawsuit even
specifies one twitch stream that
happened back in May where T foo says
faze clan are quote not doing anything
like worth the cut they're taking
they're not doing anything like worth
like the cut that they're taking arrows
and like no I am NOT a licensed lawyer I
am NOT a legal expert but with my
understanding and experience with this
case it seems reasonable to conclude
that these defenses are referring to
this and other allegedly slanderous
statements that Teague made publicly
about phase claim now to defend against
this accusation T Fu's legal team
contend that well what he said is
actually true or at least it's an
opinion which can't be proven true or
false yeah well you know that's just
like
your opinion man they also invoke
California Civil Code section 47 which
suffice to say is basically just a
defense for libel as well as New York
Civil Rights Code section 74 which if my
interpretation is correct is a defense
for reporting true accounts of legal
proceedings they even in both the First
Amendment to the United States
Constitution which in case you have been
paying attention in school is the one
about free speech now to get further
clarification on this pretty mysterious
line of defense I did reach out to the
New York lawyer representing T foo which
by the way is different than the
California lawyer and unfortunately he
never got back to me after my many many
many calls and emails to his personal
office I gotta say I like the California
guy a bit better next up is a defense
that we've heard about a million times
from t15 both in California and in New
York which is that New York is not the
proper venue according to whose legal
team for this proceeding remember that T
Fu's original contract is Gamer
agreement specified that legal
proceedings related to it had to take
place in New York now chief whose legal
team have contended the whole way
through that that Clause is
unenforceable and potentially illegal
next the defense claims that BAE's clan
can't even sue T foo for breach of
contract because that contract was no
and void from the get-go
now this defense two-phase claims
lawsuit doesn't detail exactly how
that's the case but you'll remember in t
fus california lawsuit they contend that
this contract was yes illegal and
unenforceable from the start based on
California law there's also a defense
that basically says that no faze clan
did not suffer any brand or monetary
damage as a result of T Fu's conduct and
if they did it's totally their own fault
t Fu's 10th defense invokes section 16
600 of the California business and
Professions Code which if you've watched
our previous videos on the subject you
know all about basically it's the
safeguard in California against
non-compete clauses where an employee
leaves an employer and tries to work in
the same industry for a different
employer
mantyhose really how
up on this California stuff speaking of
which teeth whose people also invoke
something called New York general
business law three four nine a KA New
York's deceptive Trade Practices Act
interestingly enough from my cursor Airy
look at this law it seems like it's
often invoked in cases where a consumer
has been bitten in the ass by a case of
false advertising in other words I'm not
explicitly sure how it would apply to
this lawsuit now remember how phase
clean accused Teague of stealing trade
secrets to start his own rival or well
the defense for that one is actually
four things one T foo came up with
whatever secret content techniques faze
clan thinks he stole two that everybody
in the public already knows these
so-called secrets three if T foo
actually did take confidential
information with him when he left phase
well faze clan should have just done a
better job of keeping it confidential
and for whatever these trade secrets
actually are basically and failed to
identify them with sufficient
particularity meaning nobody knows what
the [ __ ] they're talking about what the
[ __ ] are you talking about and then
there are a lot of defenses that I won't
go into a detail that boiled down to
this basically a breached their own
gamer agreement didn't fulfill their
obligations and therefore cannot claim
damages so what the heck does T Fu's
legal defense here actually means well
look how good these defenses will
actually function in a court of law
isn't up to me isn't up to t fus lawyer
isn't up to anyone out there except the
people involved in the actual court
proceedings in this case and that is
really the meaningful update with this
defense that these proceedings are
actually going to happen there will
literally be a lawsuit that will play
out in court unless something crazy
happens like a last-minute settlement
with this case prior to this T 15 hadn't
engaged with the New York law suit at
all they were just trying to get it
quashed or delayed now it looks like
they're prepared to actually fight some
kind of battle honestly guys like man
I'm at the point where like I don't like
I live in Toronto it's all about the
hipster beers here the IPAs people are
drinking these weird bruised that like
punch you in the face on your first sip
I'm not about it I honestly man I hate
to be a bloomer if I want to crush some
beers I need to kick back with like a
12-pack of papst like I don't
I don't give a [ __ ] dude I honestly
don't give a [ __ ] I just want to crush
those cans feel good for a minute you
know I don't need to feel the citrus
when I become a starship captain okay
you know how [ __ ] Picard goes to the
replicator he's like do you Earl Grey
hot I'm gonna be like papst cold one
baby and it's gonna materialize in my
hand I'm gonna be the sickest captain
ever